great so thanks for coming so this is
joint work with Brock hopkins Kellner
kothari and protection so there's a lot
of background for these types of
problems so i thought i'd go quite slow
in the beginning so let me first
introduce the planted clique problem
although many of you may have heard of
it before and then i'll give you a
gentle introduction to just the parts of
sum of squares that we need but what I'm
really excited about is they get for
this new tool called pseudo calibration
which I think as an interesting blend
between Beijing and computational
perspectives going on for actually
resolving one of these questions so let
me first start with the plaintiff clique
problem which is a basic and fundamental
problem in average case analysis it was
introduced independently by Jeremy
kucera actually a variant of it arose in
earlier work of carp in the mid-70s in
any case what the plaintiff clique
problem is is it's a model for random
graphs which we generate random graphs
in two steps the first step is we
generate a standard earnest rainy random
graph in which each edge occurs
independently with probability a half
now in step two that's where we plant a
click so out of these end vertices we
choose a random set of Omega of them
these are these red vertices and then we
take all if we plan to click on them
meaning that every time there's an edge
already in the ordos rainy random graph
we don't worry but if the edge is
missing we add now the catches that you
don't actually know where this click was
planted so at the end of this model
you're given a random graph along with a
promise that it really does contain a
quite large click and the basic question
is to try and find the plaintively you
can ask this information theoretically
and you can also ask it for efficient
polynomial time algorithms so the name
of the game here is really how large
does Omega need to be for efficient
algorithms because the larger Omega gets
the easier and easier the problem is
because the plant that click stands out
more and more so this is a random graph
model in fact what's known about it so
if you just care about information
theoretic low it's possible when you run
in Kwazii polynomial time there's
actually brute force search which just
looks for let's say a three log in or
something like that sighs Klee and turns
out that
for search in this case can actually
find plaintiff leaks all the way down to
roughly the information threaded
threshold that as long as the klique
you're planting is sighs at least C log
n where C is any constant larger than to
this works but really the question is
what can you do in polynomial time and
then there's actually a huge gap so let
me first tell you about a very naive
approach which there's something pretty
trivial you can do in polynomial time
which is the nodes which belong to the
plaintiff leak should have slightly
higher degree so in fact if the size of
the plaintiff click is at least root n
log n then each of the nodes that
participates in the planted klieg it's
expected degree is enough standard
deviations away from the expected degree
of all the other nodes that you can
figure out which nodes belong to the
planted cleek just by scanning through
your vertices and picking out the
vertices with sufficiently high degree
so this is a very naive algorithm based
on degree counting but it's actually not
that far off from the state of the art
in terms of what's actually known so it
turns out that you can actually shave
this extra root log factor using
spectral techniques so alon cribbage
ensued akov gave a polynomial time
algorithm that succeeds as long as Omega
the size of your plaintively is at least
c times root n for some constant C and I
should mention that there's actually a
hybrid approach that you can do a little
bit of brute force search by brute
forcing for a constant number of
vertices and then conditioning on their
neighborhood that allows you to actually
prune this constant down to any small
constant you want but you pay a huge
price in the polynomial in your running
time for your algorithm in fact
deshpande and montanari and fairly
recent work gave a nearly linear time
algorithm that's able to find planted
clicks who sizes root n overeat so this
is actually the state of the art for
what's known for this very simple
average case model in fact planted click
and the interim has found a lot of
applications because it's such a nice
model so planted click and variants of
at things like cadence a sub graph which
are harder well they found all this
laundry list of applications things like
discovering motifs and biological
networks
where the goal is to try and find within
a given graph a sub graph that actually
would be extremely rare to occur in an
odish rainy random graph so in fact
planted click is a particular type of
discovering motifs but also many other
works assume that planted click is hard
in the sense that they believe that
there is no polynomial time algorithm
for finding planted clicks of size n to
the half minus epsilon and once you
believe that that problem is hard then
you can actually get implications for a
lot of other problems expand many other
fields so for example when you talk
about computing the best Nash
equilibrium for some notion of best
social utility then it turns out that
predicated on the hardness of planted
cleat you get hardness of computing the
best Nash equilibrium tube it also gives
rise to hard problems in property
testing hard problems like sparks
principal component analysis which give
you another example of a seeming gap
between what we can do computationally
versus what we can do information
theoretically and also things like
figuring out the r.i.p constant and
compress sense it in fact there's
another way that you can exploit planted
click which is there's an inherent
information asymmetry which is if I
plank the click I know where the click
is but if i give you the graph it might
be hard for you to do swear that planted
click is and you can use this type of
information asymmetry coupled with some
conditional hardness results that do
things like construct public key
encryption schemes for you know in
cryptography and you can also use it
even within mathematical finance to
create derivatives that you've
manipulated that no one can tell are
actually lemons in disguise so planted
click has a ton of applications this is
a little bit of its Evie but really the
main focus of this talk is on you know
the question is it actually hard to find
n to the half minus epsilon size pointed
clicks so it's a great assumption which
leads to a lot of implications in its
own right but actually as we'll see
their facets of this question even known
families of algorithms which are very
powerful that were not known to fail
that could have spectacularly broken
these conjectures but just taking a step
back you know one of the major issues in
this type of direction
is that the usual way that we prove
lower doubts on computational hardness
is based on worst-case argument so
assuming things like P not equal to NP
which is a worst-case assumption then a
lot of times you can translate that
through some clever reductions in two
other implications other problems that
are hard in a worst-case sense but the
trouble is that plaintiff click is an
average case problem that's what allows
it to have so many different
applications and because of that there
are actually complexity theoretic
obstructions to hoping that the hardness
of an average case problem can be
predicated on worst-case Hardman's so
this means that the bread and butter of
you know one of the fields within theory
hardness of you know approximation
things like that are based on reductions
and that's actually not useful for these
types of problems so instead we're going
to give a different type of evidence
which is through really powerful
families of algorithms which I'll tell
you a bit more about that's where sum of
squares comes in so I'm going to try and
give you a gentle introduction to sum of
squares because sum of squares is a
fairly complex algorithm to wrap your
head around there's a huge literature on
it but let me try and compile and tell
you the minimum you need to know about
this so the sum of squares hierarchy I
think the easiest way to think about it
is through something called pseudo
expectation so sum of square is actually
started in earlier work of short
nesterov but it really took its modern
form and work of Perillo and Lasserre
it's a very very powerful family of
hierarchy of stps i'll tell you more
about that later but the way to think
about some of the square is actually to
think about it in a slightly different
way than through its proof system the
goal of sum of squares is to find some
operator this operator is e tilde
throughout this talk and it's called the
pseudo expectation operator what this
operator does it Maps any polynomial
given to it of degree at most D in n
variables to some real value so you're
looking for an operator EE tilde called
the pseudo expectation and the goal is
for this operator to behave in a
technical sense like it's the
expectation over a distribution on
solutions in this case a distribution on
large pointed pleats on a graph which
we're
so I'll formalize that later but this is
the intuition behind it and then I'll
show you what are the constraints that
we need on e tilde so that it really
does behave like it is an expectation so
there's some constraints on this
operator the pseudo expectation that are
general but they apply every time you
want to use the sum of squares algorithm
so first of all you want that eat ILDA
is a linear operator on the space of
these degree at most feet polynomials
after all the expectation operator would
be so we throw in that constraint we
want that what it does the polynomial
all one is it maps it to one so it Maps
one-to-one the expectation does that too
now this is what the real work horses of
sum of squares is in this constraint
that every time you give me a polynomial
P and you take its square the pseudo
expectation of the square of a
polynomial should always be non-negative
this is definitely true if a tilde
really were an expectation operator and
this is the workhorse behind what makes
sum of squares so powerful I should
mention that all of these constraints
I'm going to tell you they have some
caveats on how large the degree is after
all the pseudo expectation is only
defined up to the greedy polynomials so
in order for this to even make sense as
an inequality you need that the degree
of P is at most D over 2 so for every
polynomial of degree at mostly over to
this constraint better hope so it's
really important that the pseudo
expectation can't always be extended to
even higher and higher degrees because
that's actually what makes it different
than an expectation operator now there
are some constraints that are actually
particular to the plaintiff click run so
one thing to think about is that these X
of eyes you want them to behave like
they're the indicator vectors of which
vertices participate in the clip so
these X of I variables are supposed to
be 01 variables themselves and then if
you take any 0 1 variable and square it
you get the same thing as before so this
constraint just says that we're looking
for boolean solutions that every time
you give me a polynomial actually whose
degree is at most D minus 2 that you
better have the self consistency and how
the suit of expectation
operator behaves now that's let's start
actually getting into what's planted
click well we're looking for large klieg
so we want that if these really behave
like indicator vectors for a klieg then
we want at least omega of them to be on
because we're looking for large
plaintiff leaks so this constraint you
should really interpret it as being a
cleat size constraint and the last and
final constraint this is the most
important is you better be giving me a
cleat to begin with so if you think
about again these X of I variables as
being indicator variables for a klieg
then whenever we don't have the edge i J
we know that both of these can't be on
perhaps neither of them are on because
if they were it wouldn't have been a
click so this constraint just tells us
that every time we apply the pseudo
expectation operator to a polynomial x x
I times XJ where I j is not an edge we
better get the value zero because the
pseudo expectation is looking for a
cleat so this is the mouth full of
constraints this is the most technical
part in the talk is wrapping your head
around these types of constraints but
let me try and digest this a little bit
for you so we have the general
constraints on the studio expectation
and we have those that are specific to
the plaintiff clique problem now the way
to think about this is exactly as I was
alluding to that what would be a good
pseudo expectation operator is imagine
if a I threw a n really is the indicator
vector of some Omega size click in a
graph well then we actually could easily
define a good soo expectation which
meets all of these constraints given
some polynomial in these variables all
we would do is we would plug in whatever
the indicator variables are for it and
lo and behold that actually would meet
all of these conditions you know one way
to think about it is why does it meet
condition 5 it's just because if you
give me this polynomial and i plug in
this indicator vector i am going to get
omega because it's an Omega size click
this constraint holds because it is a
click and it's easy to check each of
these different conditions now this is
great but you know the important thing
is that pseudo expectations are not just
distributions on solutions after all I'm
not trying to say that we can solve
click problem in general they can
actually be quite different than actual
distributions that's why this word
pseudo is so key in the stock everything
I say should be couched with the word
pseudo because these aren't actually
distributions but in fact the important
thing is that there is an efficient
algorithm for any constant D to find an
operator the pseudo expectation operator
that meets these conditions if it exists
so if there really is a plan to click we
know that there would be a pseudo
expectation operator which would be the
evaluation map but in general you give
me a graph you give me a bunch of these
constraints and an end of the D time I
can find some e tilde operator that
behaves like it the workhorse behind it
is that constraint three really amounts
the checking positive semi-definite ness
of some end of the D by end of the D
matrix and that's really what's going on
but this is called the level B sum of
squares algorithm as you increase the
you get a more and more powerful family
of algorithms that for any constant D
still runs in polynomial time and
actually this algorithm is incredibly
powerful so let me tell you a little bit
about its CV yep so what degree is the
converse true what degree is a pseudonym
exactly exactly yeah so at n you are
actually getting a distribution but the
issues that you actually are getting
strictly more power as you increase the
because you're getting higher and higher
levels of consistency checks now you
know SOS is a huge field so let me just
tell you a bit about its CV right so
there are many other hierarchies of
algorithms there things like Sheryl Lee
Adams lavash Shriver LS plus it
strengthens all of them for what that's
worth but what's actually amazing is the
fact that actually there are problems
like the uni games conjecture which we
knew integrality gap instances which are
very strong for all of these weaker
hierarchies and it was kind of amazing
that actually SOS knows how to solve all
of those instances in polynomial time so
for things like the unique games
conjecture which caught one the neblina
prized for its actually a conjecture
that would have terrific implications
for hardness of approximation it's not
even known whether the sum of squares
algorithm break Scott's unique games
conjecture we
of no instances that actually fool SOS
so in fact showing lower balance for
this algorithm is actually something
which even for well studied conjectures
we don't know you know whether SOS
believes it or not it's also very
successful as a convex relaxation for
various problems like sparks escot
unique games there's also this beautiful
work of Lee raghavendran Sawyer that
show that among certain types of
problems certain types of random csps
that it turns out to be optimal in terms
of its size among all poly size LPS so
I'll just mention that briefly it's also
one of the best known algorithms for a
lot of average case problems like
planted sparse vector dictionary
learning no easy tens of completion
tensor PCA now with the stock is really
about is what happens when when when
such a powerful algorithm is actually
faced off with planted cleat so in fact
what woods yet so far it sounds like an
algorithm for proving something doesn't
it ah Oh certifying yeah so how does it
what does it mean to say it is an
algorithm for adventure PCA so it's an
algorithm that can be leveraged you know
these types of families of stp
constraints to give you algorithms for
noisy tensor completion so there are
these issues between like translating
between the certification problem let's
say for plane to click certifying that a
random graph G on one half actually
doesn't have a large CLE versus the
problem of actually finding it as far as
you know we don't actually know a
difference between these problems but
we're going to show a lower bound for is
actually the certification problem which
I'll get into what the relationship is
between those maybe later so in any case
you know the main question this talk is
believe it or not the following question
is open for this very concrete family of
algorithms defined by pseudo expectation
actually this conjecture about planted
click could have been spectacularly
false it could have been the case that
actually there are polynomial time
algorithms for finding not just end of a
half minus epsilon but end of the
epsilon sized planted clicks so what
happens when you pit SOS against pointed
click
uncle quick question can as well as do
something discontinuous liked i sholy i
take a make input matrix a show of
entries and do something no no so how's
that yeah exactly exactly so a lot of
those things those algorithms sometimes
it runs in Kwazii polynomial time
because it takes a high degree of a
polynomial as a you know as a surrogate
for taking the Infinity norm or
something like a baby yeah yeah exactly
all right so let me tell you our results
so we show a nearly optimal lower bound
against SOS and what's cool about this
is it kind of comes from taking a
computational bajan perspective whatever
that means i'll digest that for you
later what we show is that the
integrality gap of the level d sum of
squares hierarchy is at least end of a
half minus root d over log n so the
parse what the statement means is that
whenever you plug in D equals little ova
log n so instead of just D is constant
he is a hundred where you still get an
ungodly high polynomial time algorithm
even if you take it to be a very large
super constant you're still not able to
find better than roughly Rudin size
planted clicks so this is for one
particular formulation of that the
regular formulation the regular
formulation yep yep so this actually
improves upon a line of work that was
started off by Mecca potassium bickerson
we build very heavily on these papers
it's later improved by deshpande
montanari and then hopkins at all so
what I'll do before I really get into
what pseudo calibration is I want to
tell you about some of the key insights
about from these papers and how that
actually leads to the notion of pseudo
calibration so in fact you know aside
from the results what I really want to
tell you is this new approach which is
called pseudo calibration which is a I
think yields a lot of insights into what
makes SOS so powerful and how we can
fool it in fact what's cool about it is
whenever you take an average case
problem SOS is a very strong family
valiums pseudo calibration actually
gives you a recipe for constructing some
way to try and fool it and in fact one
of the exciting things is what we
believe is that when this recipe fails
there's some intuition that actually
that means SOS has lurking within
some interesting new polynomial time
algorithm for other problems waiting to
be discovered so I'll just mention that
is a little bit of philosophy now let me
roll up my sleeves and let's be concrete
about some of these things so let me
tell you a little bit about some of the
previous work and some of the insights
into where those things break down what
I first want to tell you about is
something called the mecha protection
figures in moments so really the
question just to refocus is we're trying
to understand can we fool SOS into
thinking there's a very large planted
click even in a graph like GN one-half
so what this means is for even you know
if I was given a graph which really did
have a planted click I could fool you
into thinking there's a plane to click
even on just the random part two so this
is one of the issues of trying to use
SOS them to try and find it but let's
focus on this question is you're given a
graph from GN one-half it only has size
log in please but how can I create a
pseudo expectation operator that is
wildly different than an expectation but
still meets all of these
self-consistency constraints of the
pseudo expectation so the usual approach
is actually to take these weaker
hierarchies and actually adapt the
integrality gaps in some way to stronger
hierarchies the amazing thing is that
this actually works for a lot of random
CSP problems like reg or even shown of X
work but something actually goes wrong
with planted pleat which will begin to
sew the previous the best things that
are known about weaker hierarchies safai
gun crowd gamer showed a nearly optimal
lower bound that they showed that the
level d l s plus argue that again can be
solved than n to the o of d time that
gets fooled into thinking that there's a
root n over two to the D size click in
an earnest rainy random breath and if
you take their approach and try and
translate it into pseudo moments well
you have to do quite a bit more work but
what mecha potassium vickerson showed
was actually that the level d SOS
hierarchy actually has integrality gap
at least n to the 1 over d now this is
quite interesting because you know
actually if d gets larger and larger you
might actually
that maybe there's some hope that SOS
really can find tiny plaintiff leagues
let me tell you about what their pseudo
expectation operator gives to do is the
following well the suit of expectation
operator is linear let's first consider
it just on monomials so I'll use this
notation X sub a to denote the product
over X I of all I na and what the mpw
moments do is you can ignore this
constant it's not really important is if
a is a clique they set it to Omega over
n to the size of it so the intuition
behind this is that you know let's say
the size of a is deep so you're looking
at all sighs the cliques in a random
graph and there are roughly a constant
times and the d of them so what you're
doing is you're trying to hide as much
information as possible and treating it
like the actual distribution on
solutions should be roughly uniform over
those size d clicks now what you can do
then is you can extend it by linearity
to all polynomials whose degree is at
most D and this is what their approach
was and eventually what they do is you
know with this pseudo expectation
operator in mind what they need to do is
actually show that it meets all of those
constraints and their main technical
tool are certain types of spectral
bounds on very dependent random matrices
not going to get into that either but
you know subsequently deshpande
montanari improved their analysis and
actually for D equals 4 we're able to
show an end of the one-third lower bound
and Hopkins kothari and protection for
any D showed this type of lower mounting
and you can check that actually for D
equals 4 it recovers deshpande montanari
is a special case great but you know
these bounds are actually tight in the
sense that these bounds really don't
work beyond the size 40 mega that's
actually one of the main things that i
want to emphasize is what goes wrong
because that's what's going to lead us
to sudo calibration and to a type of
computational bajan perspective so this
is you know one of the main technical
parts want to get across as what goes
wrong with those moments so here's an
abstraction of what's going on is you
know what I'm alluding to is the fact
that these NP w moments do not work
beyond this threshold
but the idea is actually to construct a
polynomial that actually tells you
something fishy is really going on with
the way these npw moments are set so the
key is that this polynomial is actually
itself going to have coefficients that
are random variables depending on the
actual graph that you're given so if
you're given some earnest rainy random
graph I'm going to use the notation gij
that are note the plus one variable if
it's an edge and the minus one otherwise
and what we're going to do is we're
going to consider the following explicit
random polynomial so given some graph G
and given some index I where I is a
vertex what we're going to do is we're
just going to sum over all j not equal
to i of g IJ XJ all raised to the LF L
so this is a polynomial but let's see
what happens right so if we were given
this polynomial and we care about its
expectation when we were actually given
a sample with a large planted klieg what
I claim is that this expectation is
actually quite large the way to think
about this is there's an Omega over N
chance roughly that the iif vertex is in
the clique and if it's in the planted
click then all of these other neighbors
of it are all ones and everything else
is zero and all of those edges
correspond to plus ones so we get at the
end of the day as we get an Omega in
here raise the L with power and then
square it again so we get omega over n
times Omega to the 2l but something
fishy is going on which is that when G
is actually sampled from GN one-half the
distribution that we want the fool SOS
into thinking behaves like this one then
what actually happens if we take the
expectation of the mpw moments over a
random graph g what really doing is
we're taking this polynomial and we're
squaring in but the issue is that each
of these variables g IJ is itself
independent so the only way that we get
contributions whose expectation is non
zero is that we actually mate variables
so that this g IJ variable occurs twice
when we expand it out
so even though it looks like we have end
of the 2l choices because we have a
degree 2l polynomial you really only
have n to the l choices you get n to the
l times well these variables are trying
to behave like omega over n these X of
eyes because you want to convince
someone that each vertex has roughly the
same chance of being in a plane to
cleave so you get an omega over n to the
l now the trouble is that these two
things are different so already you can
see that something fishy is going on
which is that when M is actually two
large when it's close to root n then
actually this quantity is way too small
compared to what it should behave like
on the actual distribution we want to
fool you into thinking it comes from so
in fact what this can do is you can
massage this into an actual violation of
those pseudo moments that you can
actually use that example they construct
an explosive polynomial whose su
expectation really is negative so SOS
wouldn't actually be fooled beyond its
and the intuition behind this which is
now we finally get to the notion of
pseudo calibration is that we're trying
to be too aggressive actually say good
pseudo expectation is trying to behave
like an expectation that it's trying to
hide information about what vertice is
actually participated in the plaintiff
klieg and it's trying to do so to
convince you that you've learned nothing
about which vertices do in which
vertices down what you do learn
something when you see a random graph
which is some nodes just by chance we'll
have a standard deviation more degree
than others and what you should really
be doing is you should think that those
vertices are actually a constant factor
higher probability of actually having
been in the planted cleat so this is a
type of constraint a type of
probabilistic deduction that sum of
squares can make that the other weaker
hierarchies cannot and you really do
need to take this into account to have
any hope of fooling it so you know just
taking a step back there's actually a
fix that you can do for D equals 4 so
Hopkins at all independently
raghavendran trim actually took this
example of polynomials that breaks and
explicitly added a correction term for
it these are the only polynomials that
go wrong and then you can show an end of
the half
minus little of one integrality gap and
the idea is to add these correction
terms for these polynomials to
explicitly make their expectation over
there pseudo expectation be what it
should have been in the plaintiff graph
distribution to begin with but you know
one of the troubles is asking whether
you can extend this to higher degrees so
even Ford equals six the issue is that
you can look at what L goes wrong what
types of polynomials have negative
pseudo expectation of their square and
the trouble is that you need fixes for
each of those but each of those fixes
then have their own random matrix like
terms that cause some other deviations
those actually have to be fixed too so
the fixes need fixes which need fixes
which need fixes I think it goes out at
least three levels but the real trouble
is that you know extrapolating it's not
so clear whether you can actually carry
this out that you know each of these
fixes it's very subtle with how to
actually pick the right constants in
front of it so we're going to find a way
to actually tune these Corrections based
on pseudo calibration so let me
introduce pseudo calibration so what
went wrong with the mpw moments was
really this that there was a simple
function which was Kellner's polynomial
which these two quantities behave
differently the expectation of the
pseudo expectation was different than
the expectation under the plaintiff
distribution so that was some type of
beige and reasoning that SOS was able to
take advantage of to refute those
moments but maybe we can try and make
this equality hold for all simple
functions in fact for all polynomials f
that are low degree in both the g IJ
variables and the excise of which elders
polynomial is a special case so the
interesting thing is that actually once
you have this definition in mind
everything becomes very formulaic
although technical so if we're thinking
the pseudo expectation operator let's
focus on just one monomial we take X a
and with this monomial fixed then what
the pseudo expectation operator is
itself depends on what the graph is that
you're given right for example if the
graph has a not being a clique you
better map at the zero but
general it could be some other function
of when it is a CLE you need to figure
out how to take the graph and map this
particular suit of expectation to a real
value and let me define the Fourier
characters so in fact we can take a
graph t and we can look at the product
over all edges that belong to t of this
gij now what this tells us is that
because the pseudo expectation of this
monomial is itself a function from the
graphs to a real value we can write any
such function in terms of its Fourier
expansion that's immediate right so we
know that whatever this function is it
has the property that it's some sum over
graphs of some constant the Fourier
coefficient of T times this character
kaity of g and the real question is now
not you know how should we construct the
su expectation but how should we choose
the Fourier coefficients and the
interesting thing is that once we choose
pseudo calibration as our desiree de
then the Fourier coefficients are
completely determined for us so we can
use this expression for you know this
Fourier decomposition for the pseudo
expectation and we can just plug in one
particular simple function which is a
low degree polynomial of the exes and a
low degree polynomial of the gij
variables and we can write it out so by
linearity we can pull out this kaity of
g because the pseudo expectation is
linear so this is just the constant that
depends on the graph and then lo and
behold we can actually use this
expression immediately and pull the
expectation in sign but the key is that
when we're working over yosh rainy
random graphs then these different
characters are actually orthogonal to
each other under this measure so this
means is that this quantity right here
is one if t equals T Prime and it's 0
otherwise so at the end of the day what
this tells us is that this quantity is
true that this expectation of the pseudo
expectation is exactly the Fourier
coefficient but now we can leverage
pseudo calibration because pseudo
calibration tells us we want this to be
equal to the expectation of this
quantity but over the plaintiff
distribution so now everything is
for us because we can compute whatever
this term is it turns out to be this
expression it's just omega over n raised
the size of the union of the vertices
and t which is a graph union a so
everything is completely prescribed for
us on say XA is taken in the right hand
side is taken to be the indicator on the
cliq right the plant yes yeah exactly so
all I'm saying is once you have pseudo
calibration you compute this from the
Fourier expression and you want it to be
equal to this and you can compute
exactly what this is this is what this
quantity works out to be it's a pretty
elementary calculation but now that's
great because what this means is that
you know actually once we choose to do
calibration our recipe is already fixed
we know what these Fourier coefficients
have to be which tells us what the
pseudo moments need to be themselves
there's a minor issues we need to
truncate so I'll tell you a little bit
more about that but Souter calibration
is the main thing I want to get across
so the actual pseudo moments we use are
we cut off at some threshold cow based
on the size of VT union a so now I'm
just going to tell you the skeleton of
how the rest of the proof goes so what
we can show it's not too hard to show is
with this notion of pseudo moments with
this explicit definition it follows by
elementary concentration balance things
like hyper contractivity that if you
look at how much II told of 1 deviates
from one you can bound it based on
whatever the threshold tau is this is
actually the reason why we need to
truncate is because if we went out to
extremely high degree terms
corresponding to bigger and bigger
graphs T then those high degree terms
would deviate way too much to be able to
control but if you actually choose how
to be about log n then what you can do
is you can make this deviation be
extremely small enough so that you can
actually correct it make it be exactly
older one and the same types of
deviations allow you to show that things
like the sum of X I is also very close
to Omega they actually fool another SOS
constraint you know the rest of the
skeleton is actually this is kind of
neat is once you have this definition
things just kind of fall out for free so
one thing which was really the meat of
the can
strains as we better have that you know
if a is not a click in the graph then we
want the pseudo expectation of X a to be
zero that's a hugely important
constraint in plane typically because
we're looking for a cleat you don't
actually see that occurring anywhere in
this definition but it turns out that
this constraint actually follows from
just 48 expansion of the end and
grouping together different terms it's
actually the reason why we chose this
strange way of truncating instead of
just looking at the number of vertices
of tea we Union it with it and the other
thing that one can prove is that it
actually is pseudo calibrated so I'm
going to omit all of these proofs
obviously since I've got about seven
minutes left but I'll tell you just a
little more piece about what the main
technical thing is once you have this
recipe those ulemas are pretty easy to
prove but actually there's a huge
elephant in the room which is the really
hard thing in all of these lower bounds
is actually proving positivity that for
all polynomials p the pseudo expectation
of p squared is non-negative so this
step is always the most challenging in
SOS lower bounds as usual and what this
really boils down to is proving that a
particular matrix as PSD this is what
the matrix is and this matrix is the
same type of matrix that arise in the
SOS algorithm that proving this
positivity really amounts to checking a
PSD ness condition of a huge matrix this
matrix is indexed by size these subsets
of I and J but there's a huge issue that
actually rises the bulk of the technical
work in the paper is actually proving
that ms PSD the goal is to actually
write M approximately as some PSD
factorization where if you think about
this settee that's a graph and it's a
graph that connects I and J because
that's the set that indexes the rose and
the set that indexes the columns so what
you really want this to write it as some
sort of factorization this way where K
represents the size of some sort of
minimum separator between I&J that's the
underlying graph theory so we can think
about one such graph imagine this rutile
though I'm going to call it R and it
connects this I to this j the idea is to
actually look for the leftmost
right most separators that gives us a
way of decomposing the graph and then
what happens is that this is the thing
that's supposed to be lk this is the
thing that's supposed to be qk this is
supposed to be lk transpose and that's
where the symbolic factorization comes
from is to try and write it this way
there's a huge issue which is that in
this decomposition you're assuming that
whatever graph you get out of this piece
is disjoint from this graph and it's
disjoint from this graph except that the
boundary vertices so what really happens
is when you have overlaps between it
those are huge error terms in the
approximate factorization that you need
to handle and the idea is to keep
cutting away the graph so instead you
look for separators that separate I from
the repeated vertices and from j and
similarly and that gives you a new term
in your decomposition that it turns out
that you can charge these error terms
against everything else that's going on
in the decomposition so there are a
number of problems with this but I won't
get into that let me actually you know
recap and actually step back and think
of summary of this I hope you go to this
talk is first of all we prove nearly
optimal lower bounds against SOS for the
plan to click problem despite the fact
that this assumption that you can't beat
end to the half you can't get into the
half minus epsilon in polynomial time
was a widely used assumption is actually
not known that these very concrete
powerful algorithms like SOS don't
already break that assumption much the
same way it's not known that they don't
already break things like the unique
games conjecture but we give us we give
a tool which we call pseudo calibration
which is you know when you're trying to
fool SOS into thinking one distribution
behaves like another distribution
they're all of these soft constraints
like when you have a high degree vertex
you should update what your posterior is
on the chance you think it belongs to
the klique now the issue is that there
are no real distributions these are
pseudo distributions so introduce pseudo
calibration as a way to handle all of
these low degree functions but it gives
you an immediate recipe for constructing
how you should try and fool SOS and I
think as an algorithms person is
exciting is that maybe when this recipe
fails it means that SOS really is
powerful
already been powerful in a lot of
different settings but it gives you at
least an easier way to check whether you
should be optimistic for your problem I
let me say something purely speculative
in conjectural because you should say at
least one such thing in a talk so I
wonder you know taking a step back we're
talking about an average case problem
like planted plea and the main issue is
that you know how do we actually have
evidence that this problem is hard we
can't rely on worst-case assumptions
like P versus NP but we can prove lower
balance against very powerful families
of hierarchies I'll call that SOS
evidence there are other types of
evidence for average case problems being
hard you know things like community
detection with many communities so are
there any connections between SOS
evidence and BP evidence or what happens
when they disagree all right so I'll end
there so thanks and any questions you
guys have asked for any questions any
questions on huh deep level of the
higher up here it basically is tough to
spend like empower OE right yes other in
strong evidence that this is arrived
right time or can it be like totally dr
square of in some special cases one
actually can do it in two to the deep
time but those are very particular so
actually per Sode and david know a lot
about this about speeding up these types
of things but in general as far as we
know it it does seem you know not for
particular problems but in general it
seems that one requires end of the d
just because you have to write down that
darn matrix to begin with so if you talk
about that you know that positivity
constraint that a tilde P squared is
always non-negative well that's ranging
overall peas which are degree at most D
over 2 which then the natural way to
interpret that is as an end of the D
over 2 by end of the D over 2 matrix
which then you want to be PSD so you
know at the very least and a lot of
problems you do have to write that down
although in some cases you can actually
circumvent that issue and solve SOS much
faster
related to each age for example so can
it be a um let's see yeah that's a good
question i'm not sure off to take that
offline but thanks so that the question
so you will enter the one half minus
little o of square root of ah d / wagga
wagga nobody would be great yeah so
question is so do you think this is the
correct order or or is it the new
Chicago I want to say it beats it just
because I want to be optimistic so let's
say it beats her up without the evidence
but I'm really not sure about that
some examples so I'm not sure so what I
meant by this and I would love to know
the answer to this it's just you know if
one took cavity methods and replica
symmetry breaking as evidence for
hardness of average case problems I
wonder if there's any connection between
pseudo calibration and that although
that's a purely speculative thing so I
wonder if there's any commonality in
what constitutes evidence but I don't
know purely conjectural so you mentioned
that the you said that the main problem
with the previous constructions was
inhomogeneity and the degree of vertices
if you focused on a random regular
graphs older that's tricky to obtain up
around does anyone have I guess you
would still have inflammation 80 and
things like the number of triangles a
quite exactly so there I mean that
wasn't to see richer exact barsky's
regular exactly once you have something
that actually once you have a sub graph
count that really should change your
some notion of a computational posterior
whatever that means then it does seem
like SOS takes into account that type of
reasoning so one thing that you can say
is you could optimistically hope that
you know this type of self-consistency
in the suit of expectation is some
notion of like a computationally bounded
but sort of Bayesian player to the game
but as soon as you don't take into
account things like the deviations and
triangles you exactly would probably be
able to construct some sort of fooling
polynomial for the natural moments so if
I really want to fool SOS I want to cook
up a graph which has a large click but
where for all smaller sizes of motifs
the light I logically yeah glad that the
graph with smugly I wonderfully think of
the
okay i'm still getting good yeah it
takes a little bit of digestion and
stuff found on any other questions yeah
so this is the SS arc is a standard
hierarchy that does not depend on the
problem but sometimes you can design
hierarchies that are really much
stronger yes absolutely absolutely so
for example I mean there's there's a few
works on that but you know a lot of
times if there's a lot of symmetry in
the problem then you can really exploit
the sort of sparsity in what you need is
a dual stiff good likes actually
exploiting the symmetry so I think
there's a lot of hope for actually
explaining things like you know
representation three to create different
types of hierarchies for very specific
problems but so morally so this lower
bound would also holds for something
like that um so I'm not sure see I think
that depends on which problem so if you
create a problem with a huge amount of
symmetries now I believe that there
actually is a way to create a better
hierarchy that's somehow more concise by
exploiting the symmetries I'm not sure
about SOS because you know after all for
things like random csps when you allow
general a random CS pues me allow
general stps there is this lee
ragavendra story result that shows that
actually lower bounds for SOS on the
size imply lower bounds in general so
there is a sense in which there you
can't really you know hope to use these
types of asymmetries that much so I
think it's very problem dependent all
right uh let's thank the security
you